hello hearties all over the world come
on in you know the drill at this point
we're doing yet another virtual live
event
celebrating season eight of when calls
the heart
you know me i'm deidre behar and today i
am one lucky girl because
it is ladies day i'm joined by some of
our
favorite gals from hope valley please
help me welcome
johanna newmarch eva born
kayla wallace andrea brooks and our new
queen
natasha burnette hi guys
[Music]
how's everyone doing you all look
beautiful thank you
you're doing well it is you know it's
we're still virtual we're still at home
but we are still so passionate and we're
so invested in everything going on in
hope valley i want to get
right into it um of course uh coming up
on sunday we're going into
episode four of when calls the heart and
i'm really really excited because
natasha we're gonna be meeting your
character
minnie so if you could just tell me a
little bit about
minnie what we can expect and and what
has your experience on when calls the
heart been like so far
well minnie is this really strong
she's intelligent uh she's such a caring
woman
and uh she comes in but
and she really has her her own way of
doing things
and it's such a nice sort of dynamic
that she
she brings i think to the show and a
different dynamic as well
which is really nice and it was just fun
to play something um
from that time period and uh
being on set was great because i already
knew johanna
and andrea i'd want to go for them
before
so it was really nice to sort of see
faces that i knew
um i hadn't known viv before
but we got along really really well so
it just felt like we knew each other
the whole time yeah well i i think it's
so awesome that everybody on one calls
the heart
brings something unique and different to
the table every character really shines
in their own way
what are you most excited for fans to
really
uh learn from from many or take away
from what
she brings to the town she
i feel like she's such a well-rounded
character
that it would be so nice if the fans
could really just see
all her different levels and just know
that
in all of that she just means well and
she has so much love for her family
and she's just it's very difficult
situation
for her to be in town uh with her kids
and her husband isn't as cautious as she
is
so you know i think a lot of fans will
understand
and just understand her journey as she
sort of goes back and forth between
feeling comfortable there and then i'm
sure again so
yeah well i have a feeling she's gonna
tug at our heartstrings in the
absolute best way i i think fans
can't help but notice i believe you have
a british accent is that what i'm
hearing
yes how is it doing your accent
on the show do you stay in um
in mini mode all day do you go back and
forth
uh i don't stay in mini mode all day i
do go back and forth
because funnily enough i find because of
the time period the language
was a lot like the british english
back in that time as well and that we
use now
so there are a lot of more similarities
so it's actually almost in certain
respects easier
to fall into the accent okay i was going
to say are there any tips or tricks for
you to kind of
quickly switch that on
but it sounds like it's pretty natural
for you yeah i don't know it's just like
the minute they say action i turn into
minnie
i love it well i know we're all so
excited to meet minnie and the rest of
the canfield family on sunday
um i know it's gonna be an episode like
all the rest completely jam-packed with
love and action and romance
um eva i want to go to you now i would
love to know a little bit
about the journey that your character
clara is on you know that we saw
the classy wedding in season seven and
it was so beautiful
and now in season eight it kind of feels
like you know they're realizing that
near
isn't exactly a walk on easy street what
can you tell me about that
i think you're definitely right in that
department
they are learning as a young couple that
it is
very difficult being married especially
in your first
year um i mean for them this is the
first time they're living together so
they're
really intertwining their lives um and
getting to know one another on a
completely different level
um and i think that clara is now coming
to this point in her life where
she's surrounded by you know strong
women and she's really taking on this
sort of characteristic of them
um asking for what they want and
i think she's finding sort of the
well in the choppy waters of how to
balance
you know asking for what you want but
also trying to
show your love as well for your partner
um
but yes jessie and clara have a far way
to go in the ups and downs of this
season
you know i think it's wonderful that
you're showcasing a real marriage that
nothing is all
sunshine and rainbows uh but but for you
who's
you know i feel like you're probably
used to you know seeing so much
positivity between the two of them
they've really been each other's rocks
to pivot and now have a little bit of
friction between the two
i mean how have you reacted to that as
an actress you know reading the scripts
and seeing where this story arc has gone
um you know it's funny because aaron and
i have talked about it
a lot um when we got the first script
and
we were excited it's something fun for
us to play and
um you know for us to be able to
really develop this strong relationship
for these two characters who
um are always changing they're growing
they're you know they came together as
um
young uh adults and now they're
you know in their mid-20s
and they're growing together but they're
also realizing that
um to grow together they have to have
their separate lives as well so
it's definitely an interesting stage but
aaron and i are really excited about
having some real friction and conflict
in um their relationship
yeah well i know um from what aaron has
told us in the past
jesse might be reverting to uh some of
his like former bad boy
ways how is clara feeling about that
not so good
um but luckily i think in this
season especially you see the
friendships and the bonds that she's
creating with these other women um
scenes
have been so fun to watch i just have to
say
they were so funny my favorites probably
yeah um but uh yeah so i think
he's definitely not enjoying this sort
of uh
reverting back into his old bad boy days
uh but you know she's
she is clara she is herself first and
foremost but she's also now a wife
and so she's learning how to take on um
the responsibility of guiding him as
well
uh so i think that he does a good job in
the rest of the scene
being able to kind of get him back on
track but i think
i mean i could be wrong i'm not married
in real life but
i think there's always sort of an aspect
of
um when you combine lives with someone
else
still trying to hold on to yourself as
an individual and who you are and i
think that's maybe what jesse is
experiencing a little bit absolutely and
uh and i know we'll stay tuned i can't
wait to see how all of their
relationship woes unfold but my last
question for you eva
um i know every couple has their own
journey i respect it you you move at
your own pace
but do you think there's any baby fever
going on between
um it's a great question
i think that i'm gonna say
not right now i think that
they have a little bit of a ways to go
i think i think both of them are eager
to have a family one day
but uh i i see we'll see a couple more
things coming down the line before baby
okay okay we'll pump the brakes on that
for now
newlywed life uh hi andrea
hi how are you it's so nice to see you
it's so nice to see you
well i have really really enjoyed
watching
uh nurse faith turn doctor faith and
really step into these
um doctor shoes and she's really owning
it and seems to be having a lot of
fun but you know it's not without a
little bit of conflict as we saw in
episode
three there was a really empowering
moment between your character and paul
green's character of course carson
um where faith is like i am demanding 50
50
uh power in this in this infirmary very
rightfully so
where is the faith and carson narrative
gonna go
as they uh navigate both being doctors
now
that is such a good question uh first of
all it was the most exciting thing to
and re-enter hope valley wearing pants
coming in with the horses on the buck
board uh and i have to thank
uh mr tinker for that um because it was
just such a strong
empowering way to start off the season
for
faith's arc um but with that
uh we have to pay attention to the fact
that faith has been in chicago
she has been presumably surrounded by
all men
while she was studying medicine over
there and finishing up her degree
and she would have had to assert herself
in a way that she probably hadn't
done before so coming back to hope
valley with all of this energy all of
this
enthusiasm was so exciting to play but
with that
of course comes a little bit of friction
um so
and paul and i have been working at this
for so long now and we know each other
so well as actors
and it was really fun to get to
play out friction in a way that we
hadn't necessarily
had the chance to do before um and of
course then you have some empowering
moments as a result of that uh faith
really proving herself she's really
standing on her own two feet this season
and she's kind of saying look i chased
my dream i studied
um i have a wealth of knowledge behind
me and i want to practice i want to
i want to be myself and that causes
a little bit of turmoil in in you know
their own way so
getting to play that has been empowering
exciting and
very interesting uh from an actor's
standpoint because it's a little bit
different from
what we've explored in the past between
faith and carson
well you you have me hooked i have been
watching you know
like everybody else like all the hardy's
in the world you know watching the nurse
face sorry now doctor trajectory and
and and her relationship blossom with
carson
and i have to tell you you just gave a
nod to the pants i do want to ask you
about the pants in a second
but in in the season premiere watching
carson's
serenade face by the water what a
picturesque and romantic moment
um first of all can you tease if there's
gonna be any more music
in in season eight of when calls the
heart and also like what was it like
filming that scene paul strumming his
guitar there for you
oh i mean what a picturesque setting
i don't think i've ever actually filmed
in that exact location until this season
and it's beautiful you look around there
were frogs
jumping in the water and you have all
the tall grass and it was just we shot
on such a beautiful day and then you
have
paul there saying i wrote a song for you
i mean it was so much fun
um and can i tease more music i
don't know that i can tease more music
per se but paul and i uh
do you know sing behind the scenes a lot
in between setups he always has a guitar
with him so
uh it was kind of a fun little nod to
what he likes to do in his real life
and kind of got to bring that to the
screen screen this season so that was
really exciting that that was such a
treat for us
hearties um kind of building off those
romantic moments where we see
faith and carson really prioritizing
their relationship
again i'm gonna say it again i respect
every couple you move at whatever pace
you're comfortable with
but is there a possibility that we could
see carson put a ring on it this season
i mean anything is possible
anything is possible um but
i will say that it has been quite
exciting to figure out
some new dynamics between faith and
carson because faith has grown up a lot
you know she went off she finished her
medical degree and she's
she's back and i kind of think of her as
a full
adult now she is who she's always
desired to be
and she chased her dre she chased her
dream um
and so we have to kind of reestablish
our connection i think that's only
natural and i'm really thankful
to john tinker for allowing us as
characters to figure
out these dynamics um you know it's not
always
peaches and cream sometimes you have to
sit down and have the hard conversations
and
figure out where you stand and i think
we have a lot of fun
figuring out and playing out all those
beats this year
wonderful well from one couple that we
have seen for a minute in hope valley to
johanna i want to move to you and i hope
that we've got
what could be a new romance blossoming
in hope
valley it has been so fun johanna to see
you
opposite jack wagner of course judge
bill avery
um the the romantic tension and the
sparks
to me they seem to be there what can you
tease
about this potential new couple well
it is such a fun cat and mouse game uh
so far uh and uh that continues on
so there's just so much room for
playfulness and
as i say you know little you know sort
of strategic moments between the two of
us seeing
feeling each other out and uh just it's
very playful and it's really fun
um and working with jack is delightful
um yeah i'm just really excited for the
fans to be able to enjoy this little uh
flirtation that we're on yeah well the
chemistry between you and jack is so
great i feel like you guys have really
mastered like such a great push and pull
where i think i think molly has the
upper hand and
and uh judge bill avery is kind of like
wait what's going on and then
it flips so i'm just curious for you as
an actress someone objective who enjoys
the show
do you think they make a good match do
you think that they should be a couple
i think that molly's sort of sweet fun
sassiness and also her heart is a really
nice counterpoint to his sort of dry
gruff uh you know sense you know
sensibilities
i mean obviously bill cares very much we
all know that he's had lots of examples
of showing his tender heart you know
particularly in
eva's wedding episode that was very
touching um you know he's a deep well
but
you know the way he presents uh you know
on the more on a surface level
is is a fun counterpoint to molly's sort
of you know feisty playful
humorous uh warm i think they i think
opposites attract and i think that uh
they're a great example of that
totally i wanna i wanna ask the other
ladies on the panel here
you know i have been rooting for bill to
find a little
romantic uh action in his life over the
past few seasons
do you guys ship bill and molly as a
couple together
100 [ __ ] yeah yeah
great have you uh johanna have you
thought about what their couple's name
would be
oh i'm gonna actually put out a uh a
little uh
yeah a little uh a poll on that one um
yup yup
and uh i and i think so far
the one that rolls up the tongue is moby
[Laughter]
i don't know we'll have to let the
friends say mobile
let's not go with mobile no yeah i think
that might be a toy company already i
think we should
um i'll let the fans help me with that
one it's not terribly obvious but yeah
okay so verdict is still out on what
their couple's name would be but you
know
we already we ship flomo in so many
different ways
these two queens together and their
friendship and and the special moments
you know the fans always really look
forward to them
can you tell us one flomo moment that is
not to be missed this season
oh yes absolutely uh without giving too
much away uh florence has a really
beautiful arc this season
and you get to see molly molly's always
been
uh 100 supportive of her wonderful
friend florence but you get to see that
deepen in such a beautiful way and
there's there's a couple schemes where
just
their friendship and their commitment to
each other as
humans and as women uh are it's just so
touching
uh we i i can't say too much more than
that but i'm just one thousand percent
there for florence and i really help her
uh when she needs it most and really
come through for her and we have a scene
of
of of us being able to express our
appreciation for each other that
was extremely touching for me to have to
film
and it was actually quite sweet because
the director kept saying you guys
you need to cry a little bit less a
little bit less because because we've
been on this journey together loretta
and i for
for eight years you know and and and so
much of our natural love and affection
for each other just came pouring out we
had to
try to like keep our keep ourselves a
little bit more in check emotionally it
was really
really touching it was you know
personally touching and then touching
very much as the characters so
yeah i love how on one calls the heart
some of these moments
like tend to like bleed over into real
life i was talking to
to viv uh natasha's of course on screen
counterpart
and he said that working with his kids
on screen it doesn't even feel like
acting he's just a proud parent
in those moments and for you johanna to
have
you know your friend loretta there after
all these years and you guys are
especially right now
in women's empowerment month um i i just
think the work that you guys are doing
is so powerful and very moving
oh thank you so much that really means
just a huge amount to me and
much like viv there's no acting required
i just i adore the women i work with and
i hope that that
comes across on screen so oh it really
does and my last question for you
johanna
the fans online are really talented and
dedicated with their flomo artwork their
fomo edits
what is your reaction to that oh i'm i'm
always just gobsmacked i i just go
what happened how is somebody this
talented how is somebody this creative
this playful this fun
it's just brought me so much joy all
through this journey but particularly
this year
you know we're all dealing with the very
many challenges before us so
their their enthusiasm and their
affection and their as i say their
creativity has just been it touches my
heart so deeply
we've i've never experienced a fan base
like this i don't think i think as all
of us have
uh and just the the kindness and love
and genuine affection that the the fans
have for these characters is
an and an endless source of genuine uh
joy for me
so yeah thank you fans thank you that's
why
i hope i believe all these these women
would gladly agree with you on that one
uh kayla speaking of women's empowerment
it's so nice to see you you are a woman
that i truly
adore and admire um very similar to your
character on one calls the heart you
know watching fiona
um really redefine what it means to be a
woman
during that time period has been so
inspiring and so empowering to watch
so for you first of all i just want to
know what can you tease for the rest of
fiona
as she continues on this journey yeah
well
so far i think we've seen her push more
boundaries like she
like she always sort of has pushed them
with her work moves and and
social norms of that time um you might
see her
get a little closer with some cast
members
and um maybe i'll just say that
whoever would it be well
i i think she's a very friendly person
and she might make a friend an even
better friend so we'll you guys will get
to see
a fun journey there okay
i will i will come back to that in a
second um
i i just want to ask you because we we
just watched
fiona in episode three um really
step up to the plate and she doesn't
hear
man you know belle says to her we'll
call if we need more men out there
she completely bypasses that and she
goes down
to uh you know not the scene of the
crime but you know what would you call
it like where the explosion occurred
and and she is not afraid to roll up her
sleeves and get dirty and and help
and um what has it been like for you
watching your character grow and blossom
in this way has it been
empowering um has it been a delight for
you to to
really watch fiona grow this season
it yeah it really has i i loved
that she got to struggle a little bit at
the beginning when
you know business was at first you know
she
couldn't get anyone in her shop she was
like who wants
their first haircut and everyone ran
away and then
um you know the cutting of the ear like
i loved
that she all of a sudden wasn't because
she's sort of been good at
what she does and gets the jobs done so
it's been fun to see her struggle a
little bit
but then also pull through and
that the scene where she
where she jumps in and helps and yeah
doesn't hear
the word man and doesn't care i l that
was
a really cool scene for me to film it
was honestly like
as as a woman coming in and filming a
scene with
like seven guys it was it was new for me
because
and i felt what that would have felt
like for her
you know that there would have been an
intimidating factor there but she
stepped up and yeah that was a really
fun scene to film
yeah she's she's doing it fiona and she
doesn't make any apologies about it
which is why i love her so much uh
i'm gonna circle back to the little
romance that you teased
uh fans can't help but you know
celebrate i i have been loving seeing so
many scenes between
fiona and who i call hickam but i've
noticed that fiona calls him michael
and i feel like that little nuance there
could possibly mean that there's there's
some you know maybe flirtation going on
or a possible
romance in the works what do you think
of that do you think they would be a
good couple
i really i really do i kayla really
they would make they they're just so
they're so opposite they're opposite
sides of the
confidence spectrum i would say like
hickam
is so sweet and so um but he's very
smart
and i think that that's something that
really connects them
um and also that he's he's just the
sweetest in real life
and in the show but i love that he's
this sort of timid little mouse and
she's this
you know confident woman and
they have a really fun dynamic and you
guys yeah
people will get to see them in
a few more scenes this season so stay
tuned
okay another romance i'm absolutely
rooting for what would fiona and jacob
be what would their couple's name be ooh
we need to start a poll on that one too
yeah
launch your poll on your instagram story
i love it
oh yeah i can't have you wonderful
ladies
uh here with me today and not ask this
question and i'm
to preface it by saying i think
inherently all of
us are team elizabeth right we just want
to see elizabeth happy
we want to see her and her son happy
together find companionship and loyalty
and a partner
whoever it may be but with that said
as it stands today natasha i'll start
with you
do you feel like your team nathan
or team lucas
can i be team lutheran
i'm sorry say that one more time team
lutheran
and why do you feel that way tell me
no um let me see i'm gonna say
you know what i feel like i want to say
nathan because
i know what happened to jack but you
know she should just
get out there let all of that go and
give it another go with a bounty
okay i like the confidence in your
response that's wonderful
andrea how are you feeling i have such a
hard time with this question
i adore both characters i adore both
actors
um and i flip-flop so i'll do one
interview i'll say nathan one interview
i'll say lucas
um this is so impossible but i want to
give an answer
so i'm thinking back to the end of
episode two
and that final scene that the that
heart crushing moment that was pretty
awesome so i'm going to say to nathan
because i i'm still thinking about that
scene
okay we've got two votes for nathan
kayla
how do you stand after this episode that
we've just been talking about
i'm going to say team lucas okay
tell me why i think there's
a there's a quality to him that's
new and that sparked something in
elizabeth
that's exciting okay but i
if if i was to step back an episode
what andrea was just saying i'm 100 team
nathan
it's hard it really does vacillate
episode to episode right it does
and it will it will keep doing it
i believe kevin mcgarry teased it as
there are more red herrings in season
eight than a zoo
not sure if a red herring is even an
animal but i liked the quote
okay so we've got one vote for lucas two
votes for nathan eva where do you stand
okay well i'm gonna have to just
even the score and say look at this one
honesty
um i i think like everyone's saying i go
back and forth
constantly um especially this season
just reading episode
episode and uh but
i'm gonna say lucas because i've always
loved
that they have this um bond over
storytelling and novels and
um reading and that's obviously
something that's so
influential and and intrinsically
elizabeth
so i love that um lucas is able to bring
that
even more out in her and support her in
that
um so i say lucas all right johanna
pressure's on we've got
oh this is totally unfair
okay i'm sorry this is not just because
i'm the tiebreaker but i have struggled
with this
this triangle for so long because as the
ladies have said that both the
characters are so compelling
uh as humans as actors uh you know let's
be honest they're both
you know very easy on the eyes um and i
think that
it's a testament to john tinker's
writing that what we're talking about
this season is that from episode to
episode that we
feel strongly one character and then we
feel strongly another character because
he's written such compelling storylines
uh and reasons for her her uh you know
her
her heart being so torn and as a woman
and as a viewer i so feel that i go
oh this is so agonizing because they're
both so special and so
you know compelling on so many levels
how does one choose how does one choose
and so i hate to say this and it only
gets worse because i know
how the season goes and there's certain
things that are revealed about both
characters that make you love them even
more
um this is terrible it's horrible i i
honestly cannot choose i mean as a woman
of a certain age
i will definitely say that lucas's
consistency is worth a lot that you can
take consistency to the bank
in a long-term life partner especially
as a woman who has a child she needs
someone who's got her back consistently
day in day out yet year in year out
um but there's so many other wonderful
qualities about nathan and also i can't
tease it but there's a really big thing
coming up this season
where we understand so much more about
his hesitation to declare his love for
her
which he so boldly did last episode
which was so touching i
was extremely emotional after that
episode um
so i think as a compassionate human i
know
about declaring his love so it makes me
uh really empathic towards his
characters sort of what can seem like
maybe
lack of courage or vacillation so i'm
i'm terr i'm [ __ ] i'm so sorry ladies i
can't choose
and i'm not just saying that i can't i
can't
i can't i love them both think about it
like this
if elizabeth was your best girlfriend
and she came to you with this
predicament and said i've got
chocolate ice cream and vanilla ice
cream and i love ice cream i love both
of them so much
which one has the .0001 competitive
advantage over the other
okay before ladies gave answers i i
can't let you get off the hook
it's all mean so mean okay so i'm gonna
answer it based on where we are in the
season right now okay so coming up on
episode four
so far i have to say that his
consistency holds a lot of weight
so i would say lucas based on where we
are now but
like all these ladies said and all like
fans out there
i that that feeling may change okay
final score today three for lucas two
for nathan
and i i know that obviously you ladies
know uh where that journey
ends by the end of this season you know
the decision that she makes
i'm hoping you can give me your best
poker faces no spoilers here
what can you tell me about the finale
how did you react when you read the
script what kind of emotions were
running through you how do you think
fans are going to feel natasha let's
start with you
um do you know the way that things came
together in that final episode
it was just the perfect
sort of moment to just realizing
everyone's story lines i think that it
was just
a perfect symbol of hope valley at its
best
i really felt like that and it was it
was such a happy moment just to see even
for my story
and elizabeth's story and everyone's
story just to see where it ends it's
for now it's just like wow yeah yeah i
think the fans will really enjoy it
i think whatever they thought about um
elizabeth
whether lucas or nathan i really think
they'll
they'll get to the end and still have
love for the
the other party that may have won her
heart
andrea what was going through your mind
when you read the script
i have never in my life torn through a
script
so fast um i i i
and i didn't skip because i i wanted to
make sure i got
everything and i just it just just the
feelings the feelings
they're they're lovely it's perfect it's
a great resolution you'll see
um it was wonderful
uh kayla were you as voraciously reading
through the script how did you feel
about the decision at the end
going back to what natasha said i really
think
that this season you got to see so much
of both characters that it
it's like there was no unanswered
questions it felt very um
serene i don't know is that a weird like
we
it made sense and um
yeah i mean in in real reality
half the people are gonna be
upset but i think it leaves
you know it's exciting to see where that
person will go next
to so it's like what a tough decision oh
my goodness
i'm happy fiona doesn't have to make
matches
we all are very happy we don't have to
make that decision
i think if you're a true hearty if
you're a true one calls the heart fan
you have elizabeth's best interest at
heart
so i hope there's no upset fans you know
it's like again it's the difference
between
your two favorite flavors of ice cream
you're still getting ice cream at the
end of the day and if your friend is
happy
everybody will be happy and aaron krakow
has confirmed that
neither suitor is leaving the show so
hopefully we'll continue to see
both gentlemen's journeys regardless of
what the decision is
eva i want to ask you is it hard for you
to hold on to this secret do fans
approach
you tweet you ask you uh and what's your
reaction
when people want answers yes oh it's
funny i've actually become
quite close with um one fan
and she asked me all the time like
whenever an episode ends
i noticed that you know some people were
reacting this way to lucas or to nate
i know you can't tell me anything but
just wondering what you think
um but i think like everyone else
uh i i remember actually that day i
think we
were on set filming another episode and
we'd gotten
those scripts at lunchtime so everybody
just ripped through them and then came
back
to the green room and were like did you
read it
[Laughter]
totally i imagine
yeah so i think that um and i think as
you're saying too you know
a true hardy um is gonna want what's
best
for everyone and even you know
whoever lose out loses out on elizabeth
is still going to
gain in life in some way and they're
going to find love in hope valley
um so i think yeah a true fan is just
going to want
what's best for everyone um but
yes we'll we'll see we'll see we'll see
what happens
yeah and johanna closing words on this
hot topic that fans love to talk about
oh goodness yeah the final episode i
mean as eva said it was released on a
day that most of us were there and i
think i was in the middle of shooting a
scene so i got to it
like an hour later and i was i remember
so clearly we were i was sitting in the
green what the
you know the they made abigail's into a
green room for us that we're all sort of
in holding
as it's called and uh uh i remember erin
krakow and
um and uh lucas sorry
chris mcnally were huddled in the corner
discussing something very important and
i was
sitting in my in my chair you know
flipping through it reading graciously
like a crazy person because it was i was
like sweating and like my heart was
racing as i was reading this episode
and then the end of it i yeah i i
finished it and i was like holy hannah
and they all looked at me and they're
like
and i was like oh sorry just finished
the episode guys and they're like
right i was like yeah it was just so as
ladies say it was everything was summed
up in a way
that felt right it felt good it felt it
like it had integrity and elegance and i
just thought it was a really exciting
way to end season eight because
i feel that it leads such a beautiful
opportunity into season nine
oh gosh our fingers crossed you know me
i have been rallying i want one calls
the heart season 75.
i'm hoping that you ladies are committed
for the long haul
you know we're talking about the love
triangle here and i'm obviously very
invested in that but
the show i think is so magical because
it's an ensemble it's about a community
it's about multiple people on their
different wavelengths and their
different journeys in life
and you all shine your magic on that and
and you teach us lessons and you keep us
wanting more so
i am so excited to see how everything
plays out
if you have a few more minutes i'd love
to play a quick women's empowerment
themed
game with you ladies if you're down yeah
okay cool so in honor of march being
women's empowerment month
um i just want to play a rapid fire game
i'm going to shoot you a quick question
and i would love to know
your your first thing that pops to mind
okay
so my first question natasha let's start
with you most inspiring woman in your
life
uh my mother
is she is she in the uk is she in canada
with you
she is in the uk at the moment she's
uh yeah there's she's recently told me
stories about
her life back when there when he was
working on stuff and
the things that she went through and it
just really inspired me
really inspired me well i know she is
certainly proud of you and the
incredible work that you do
is she a hearty can we confirm that she
is a hearty
she is i do
she does have a t-shirt
love it uh andrea most inspiring woman
in your life
oh i have to say the same my mom my
mom's really been for
me my mom has really been there for me
uh especially over
the past couple years i've had a baby i
work a lot and
uh she's just such a tremendous help and
she's so wonderful and i see her in a
whole new light after becoming a mom so
oh and how is your little one doing
she's great
she's walking talking uh bonking her
head
running into walls uh she's crazy and
wonderful
and she's the best what was her first
word hardy
oh i think her first word was
ball but we should not talk about that
good i'm happy to hear that she's doing
well she's such a little cutie that one
of yours
uh kayla which woman in your life
inspires you the most
i've gotta say i mean i it's a tie
between mom and sister
my sister is a mother of
two tiny little ones and i don't know
how she does it
um she's a superstar she's a rock star
and
my mom too i hope i can be
half the woman she is one day oh you
already are i know you are you're a
superstar
eva um i think i have to say
my grandmother um
she's passed away now but i was very
close with her
um all throughout her life and she was
someone who
you know she grew up in the 20s the 30s
40s and she was a trailblazer of her
time
um for what she was teaching me and you
know her experiences
at that time of being a woman um she
you know taught me how to take care of
my skin which is something i'm obsessed
with as well
well you're so gorgeous and glowing so
she did something right there yes
thank you yeah so i would have to say my
grandmother just a total trailblazer
and by the way can you share what the
like ultimate skin care tip is
um oh my gosh well i feel like there are
so many but probably i would say
okay two things um
i would say double cleansing am pm
oh actually no p.m only and then um am
just wash with water take it easy on
your skin
and then i would say sunscreen protect
your skin from the sun
i love it i'm going to go because i'm
just a nighttime
washer like yeah you know and i know so
i i love hearing what what people do to
get their gorgeous glow and you always
look
so stunning so thank we thank your
grandmother for the wisdom
thank you for telling us and johanna who
inspires you the most
uh yes it would be a split between my
mother and my daughter
um so yeah my mother's just an
extraordinary woman
i'm i'm her only child and we're
incredibly close
uh and you know i don't want to take up
too much time i could spend a year
talking about
her but she's just one of those fearless
people who has done extraordinary things
with her life and never
ever ever took no for an answer if
she anytime she put her mind to
something she did it uh
without getting into the details she
just pulled off extraordinary
feats uh professionally and personally
in her life
she would just point over the fence and
say there i'm going there and everybody
would go what are you talking about she
would sure enough she'd go do it and
she'd do it with
finesse and style and she's just an
extraordinary human
she's the strongest most feisty powerful
she's a very powerful woman
nobody messes with my mom and she really
taught me that she
absolutely taught me her your worth and
that people will treat you like you
like you let them treat you so that's
huge and then my daughter who's uh
22 going to be 23 she's just i've been
really inspired by how she's handled the
challenges of this uh last year
uh you know without talking too much
about the tedium of
of the you know work of covid um you
know she had to she was wrapping up her
her degree at the university of
edinburgh amidst very challenging times
and she had to
you know finish her dissertation and
quarantine and she still managed to get
a first which was the
for those of you that's a british term
like the highest honor you can get uh
for your degree
and it's a very prestigious school so i
was just really proud of her tenacity
because you know we all had some
difficult days but she pushed through it
and she just kept saying i can do this i
can do this and then you know the
challenges of anybody trying to launch
their career in this
uncertain year uh you know it's there's
not a lot of opportunities and so trying
to keep your spirits up in your and
being hopeful about the future and i've
just been really uh inspired by her
strength
uh made me just really proud of her i'm
gonna start crying so i'm gonna stop
there
well i i she sounds like a really really
special
young lady and i i know that a lot of
that is a result of
how incredible you are and i'm sure the
the values that you've instilled in her
my last question in this game i'm i'm
fascinated by the idea of like
in another universe doing character
swaps
so natasha i'm going to start with you
if you could play
a different character on when calls the
heart who would you want to play and why
i the first name that came into my head
was hicken
and entertaining i was just like it
would be so
great to just do such a comedic role it
would just be fun
so fun you would never get
a cup of coffee
never okay
that's a great answer natasha andrea who
would you want to swap with
oh i'll say rosemary she's so
grand and fabulous and big and i love
her outfits and i think
that would be a lot of fun very
different
opposite of faith uh so yeah the other
extreme i think
well you you and paul greene really are
uh
you know two of a kind because that was
the exact answer that he gave
no it wasn't
okay rosemary kayla who would you want
to trade shoes with
okay i would want to ride a horse so
i'm gonna say nathan and i could put i
could wear a red surge
yeah oh my gosh the first
the first female cop of that era
you know i stand it you know i worship
that i love that
fiona breaking barriers yet again i hope
john tinker watches this that would be a
really interesting idea okay
eva um okay i'm gonna say
because i've really enjoyed the
storyline especially this
season so far for faith and also
basically i want that pantsuit so
andrea i didn't have a chance to ask you
about that just really quickly
the idea of putting faith in pants was
that your idea was that your brainchild
you know what when john tinker met with
each and every one of us before we
started the season
and he sat down with me and the first
thing he said he's like
next season faith comes back to town
pants
and i was just like i love it i love it
and then we proceeded to have the most
amazing meeting ever
um and so after that meeting i did my
research i went through the history
books i found some amazing
uh photographs that i've posted on my
story on instagram
and women did wear pants it was rare but
they did especially in the big cities so
that was kind of a fun thing that she
brought back with her from chicago
well she looks stylish and i love that
it's it's empowering and and something
new
so i'm all for it um okay cool johanna
we're gonna wrap up with you who would
you like to trade characters with for a
day
honestly right now i'm obsessed with
minnie and i would love to be minnie
yeah uh
i just think she's john tinker's written
a really complex
really interesting character and i'm
very touched by her advocacy uh
for her children um and her relationship
with viv i mean i'm a huge fan of viv
as a human being he's just a beautiful
man
uh and i just love their relationship i
love the depth of the relationship
and i'm just yeah i'm just really
excited about the quiet unwavering
conviction
uh you know in her in which she believes
in for her family
and also you know i i'm sure i i i think
it's always great to
change you know change choose with
someone who
sees the world for you know from a
different uh you know point of view you
know
so yeah natasha how do you feel about
doing a little switcheroo with molly
you know what whatever not let it
do this no problem i'll hang out with
bill
try and fly with me
i love that beautifully put you in here
it's truly terrific i'm just going to
end this today by kind of giving you the
floor
um you know it's been a challenging year
and one calls the heart certainly has
provided
a lot of joy a lot of uh love and
laughter and comfort to
viewers like me at home uh what what do
the hearties mean to you
what do the messages that you receive
mean to you and what does the support
mean to you
oh it means the world uh it's just so
wonderful to be a part of
one thing i admire about this fandom is
the positivity um
even if something negative is said at
some point that
the positivity far outweighs it and
we're just so lucky
um to have such amazing advocates for
our show
totally we have so many so many
amazing people rooting for us and it's
just so
great to be supported by such a
large group of people honestly it's it's
amazing like we
thank all of you guys for keeping us
employed yes and on top of that
too like it was so lovely to to work
with all of these
ladies and work with the cast that we
have
you know this year it's such an awesome
community within the show
and then the hardys is a whole other
level of community that we
so so so appreciate yeah
yeah and i i just love that i feel like
our i guess everybody in their life
wants to make wants to feel like what
they do makes a difference in the world
um you know because i remember at
different points in my career going does
what i do really matter does anybody
care
and then really feeling with this show
like i make a difference in people's
lives that i lift people's spirits
um you know help them get through tough
times those are the messages that really
touch me the most
you know when you're you'll get a
message from someone who's in hospital
getting treatment and they're just
talking about how much
their show has helped get our show has
helped them get through tough times
those are the messages that really stick
with me and really uh
you know give me that you know when
you're having a challenging where you
could just give you the
the motivation just keep keep pushing
through all the trials and tribulations
of being an actor because there are many
of them
i mean just trying to still create shows
that make a difference to people so the
the fans are they're just huge they're
they're very very meaningful to all of
us
we talk about it regularly on set so
thank you all
natasha being new to the hardy community
what has that been like for you so far
it definitely wasn't i because andrea
i spoken to andrew about this beforehand
and i
you know i was listening andrew it's
just when it actually is happening
it's a completely different moment
and i we share a manager uh and so i
think i've
and we've hung out many a time over the
year over the years and
yeah i i know it's something we had
spoken about and when you joined i was
like
yes this is so perfect i love
how dedicated they are to us and to each
other sometimes i'd see a tweet where
one heart isn't feeling good that day
and they
get multiple messages from other
hearties
just really supporting them
so it's really something to experience
yeah i'll let you close this out queen
okay um
yeah i was going to say too i mean with
now over eight seasons you know i think
the hardys have
um seen us have had some losses
in regards to characters and for them to
continue to
rally behind us and for us to allow or
for
them to allow us to continue to tell
stories
um they're everything they're just
everything
we're so grateful for them that is
beautifully put
it is so wonderful to see all five of
your faces you're doing incredible work
on when calls the heart i encourage
everybody who is watching us right now
to tune in for episode four of when
calls the heart
this sunday nine p.m on hallmark channel
i certainly will be tweeting along using
the hashtag hearties and i hope
to see all of the hardies on twitter
blowing it up let's get it trending
another week shall we
yes thank you again ladies wonderful to
see you
thank you
[Music]
you